es viernes 13 noviembre de 2015 una
noche de horror acaba de comenzar el
primer atentado tuvo lugar a las afueras
del estadio Nacional de Francia cuando
dos terroristas suicidas se inmolaron
con 10 minutos de diferencia un tercer
ataque suicida tuvo lugar menos de media
hora después el presidente françois que
se encontraba en el estadio en el que se
disputaba un partido amistoso contra
Alemania fue puesto a salvo al mismo
tiempo se producían más ataques en el
centro de la capital francesa hombres
armados dispararon a los comensales de
un café y un restaurante de la calle
Alive en el distrito 10
[Música]
minutos después abrieron Fuego en la
calle fontanoboa y en la calle Chacón en
el distrito 11
había sangre por todas partes la gente
caía como moscas era una verdadera cena
de guerra me sentía como en las
trincheras
pero el peor ataque de la noche comenzó
cuando tres terroristas interrumpieron
en la sala de conciertos bataclan y
abrieron fuego con armas automáticas
tenían como blanco 1500 personas que
asistían a un concierto de rock
[Aplausos]
un periodista de lemons que vivía al
lado filmó algunos de los asistentes al
concierto escapando por una puerta
trasera y a otros Colgando de las
ventanas intentando desesperadamente
salir algunos de los que estaban
atrapados dentro se escondieron donde
pudieron
Dos policías llegaron y mataron a uno de
los terroristas en la planta baja otros
dos estaban arriba habían tomado Rehenes
las fuerzas especiales de la policía
francesa ingresaron aseguraron la planta
baja y Los Rehenes salieron
estábamos todos tirados en el piso y vi
que disparaban por todas partes sentí un
instinto de supervivencia estábamos
todos en el suelo nadie se movía nos
tumbamos lo más bajo posible para que no
nos vieran
la gente se acostó encima de los demás
disparaban kalashnikovs como Si
estuvieran torturando a la gente se
disparaba contra la gente era una
carnicería una carnicería había muertos
por todas partes
el presidente francés se dirigió a la
nación justo antes de la media noche
con ciudadanos mientras hablo se están
produciendo atentados terroristas de una
magnitud sin precedentes en París varias
decenas de personas han muerto y muchas
han resultado heridas es un horror
y yabuku
tras intentar negociar con ellos las
fuerzas francesas asaltaron a los dos
terroristas que tenían como Rehenes a
los asistentes al concierto la operación
terminó 21 minutos después de la
medianoche Después de tres horas de
derramamiento de sangre fueron los
atentados más mortíferos en Francia
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial